what is going on everybody and welcome
to another bitcoin video we've completed
the entire breakdown of the bitcoin
paper and now we have a few implications
of that paper and also just additions to
the Bitcoin protocol that should be
discussed and understood something that
kind of perplexes me is why the year
2140 is used as you know this kind of
stopping point or target for the mining
reward of Bitcoin you know be the goal
why was that level of inflation or
inflation rate chosen as the target and
also why was 21 million max coins chosen
people argue this point saying that you
know 21 million is so you know it's
still visible really easily so it's
going to allow people to you know if the
Bitcoin is really popular or unpopular
it's easy to like work around that so
it's easier to trade like in full
bitcoins if bitcoin is unpopular and
cheap but if it's very popular in highly
priced you can move easily into you know
many decimal places since the most
divisible bitcoin is like a quadrillion
like so if you took away all of the
decimal places you would have like
twenty one quadrillion bitcoins so maybe
this answer is why something like 10
million could be the cap or why it is 21
million but why not but why not 10
million or a 30 million or 50 million so
it seems like no one actually has the
answer to this most people point to the
hash rate of the blocks and the
timeframe of difficulty but really the
math that adds up to 21 million would
really be the math that's after the fact
after the final number was decided on or
so you would think anyway so now that
you're all Bitcoin pros it is time to
erase some knowledge and replace it with
some better knowledge so remember how we
ingrained that the last block of Bitcoin
will be mined in 2140 this is actually
probably not going to be the case given
the intense rise in Bitcoin popularity
so far we're on track to actually finish
all the Bitcoin mining much earlier the
moving average change in Bitcoin occurs
every 2016 blocks so this wasn't really
covered in the paper it which is
explained that that's how they would
cover the
you know the popularity as far as mining
was concerned but this is done every
2016 blocks with a difficulty target of
10-minute solutions now keep in mind
that this is every 2016 blocks this
isn't a lifetime moving average and it
only updates once every two weeks so
it's not even a 2016 moving average it's
actually every 2016 blocks it you know
takes that bumps it up basically so as
we continue hashing out these blocks we
continue outpacing the moving average
change 2016 blocks accounts for two
weeks ideally since you've got one block
every ideal 10 minutes so six blocks an
hour 140 for a day times 14 days and
you've got yourself 2016 so if you view
the chart comparing the hash rate and
the difficulty you'll find that the 2016
true moving average difficulties moved
up perfectly to match it every two weeks
then relatively quickly that 2016 moving
average starts going way above it and
especially if you look at something like
the 504 which is the 504 moving average
of you know the hash rate you can see
that it's almost always above the
difficulty even when it updates this
means that blocks are actually being
generated much faster than intended
right now anyways and you can clearly
see the difficulty is lagging on a long
term since bitcoins inception really
this has been the case since its come
out hash rate has always been above the
difficulty because it's only risen right
so at this rate we will get the 21
million bitcoins you know much sooner
more likely before the year 2100 even
now that said the reason why people
still kind of adhere to this 2140 idea
is because it's unlikely that the hash
rate continues to always outpace at some
point as Bitcoin adoption matures the
hash rate will find itself under that
difficulty because the difficulty will
for as long as hash rate continues going
up bit or the difficulty will continue
going up but at some point that hash
rate will probably come down and it's
highly likely that the hash rate are
highly unlikely that hash rate will
actually continue to outpace you know
for a full century so if hash rate falls
below and it's below it then it's going
to be below it for two weeks are up to
simply two weeks and then it gets
updated you know and so then bitcoin
will be created at a slower pace than
intended and so in theory it probably
could still even out but at the current
pace it's scheduled to be done much
sooner than 2140 but in the end what you
should know is that 21 million bitcoin
is the true certainty the year 2140
being the end is not so anyways um
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support the subscriptions and until next
time